hallo und herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live es ist ein trauriger tag der
das gesamte vereinigte königreich
erschüttert und die ganze welt trauert
mit queen elizabeth die zweite ist im
alter von 96 jahren auf schloss balmoral
in schottland gestorben das hat ein
sprecher des buckingham palace vor
wenigen augenblicken bestätigt sie sei
friedlich verstorben heißt es
wir informieren euch und sie natürlich
hier bei zdf heute live und auch in
einem parallel laufenden zdf spezial die
letzten monate waren für die queen nicht
leicht im april vergangenes jahr verlor
ihr ehemann prinz philip das leben 73
jahre lang waren beide verheiratet im
april dieses jahr dann erkrankte die
queen an corona und ihr
gesundheitszustand verschlechterte sich
stetig sie zog sich darüber hinaus auch
immer weiter zurück und trat nur noch
selten öffentlich auf der letzte große
auftritt erinnern uns ihr auftritt zum
siebzigsten thronjubiläum zuletzt noch
vor zwei tagen ernannte sie dann lässt
das zur premierministerin heute mittag
dann aber die meldung dass ärzte sich
besorgt gezeigt haben über den
gesundheitsstatus der queen ihre söhne
prinz william und prinz charles haben
sich dann sofort auf den weg gemacht
nach schottland um abschied zu nehmen
genauso wie prinz harry später waren
dann auch alle engen verwandten zusammen
kinder und enkel wir gehen rüber nach
london zu andreas stamm am buckingham
palace unser korrespondent andreas wie
ist da gerade bei dir die stimmung wir
haben die briten auf diese nachricht
reagiert
ja sie sind zu tausenden
vor dem palast geströmt deswegen musste
ich mich dort weg bewegen ich sitze
jetzt im studio unweit des buckingham
palast ein wir haben technische probleme
bekommen durch die unglaubliche zahl der
menschen mit ihrem mobiltelefon dieser
frequenzen blockieren also man muss
sagen die trauer setzt jetzt ein viele
können es kaum fassen das ist eine sehr
gedämpfte
emotionale stimmung und ja viele
londoner wollen abschied nehmen von
ihrer queen versammeln sich da vor dem
buckingham palast wo auch dann eine
offizielle verlautbarung dann noch
ausgehängt wird die flagge weht auf
halbmast
und ich glaube es sichert so langsam ein
dass diese ära
70 jahre auf dem thron vorbei ist und
natürlich war das jetzt ein abschied auf
raten das ist jetzt nicht überraschend
keine frage aber dann kommt dieser
moment und ich glaube egal ob royal ist
oder nicht es gibt natürlich auch hier
gegner der monarchie so ist das nicht
aber alle die dort sind und ich glaube
jeder auf der straße ist erstmal
geschockt und verdrückt auch die eine
oder andere trainer andreas was es aus
deiner sicht über die letzten stunden
jetzt von der queen bekannt wie lief das
ab und was weiß man auch über die
todesursache weiterhin
also da es bis jetzt natürlich noch
nicht veröffentlichte noch die frage ob
da überhaupt etwas dazu gesagt wird es
ist eben sie friedlich eingeschlafen
heißt es schon heute am nachmittag
darüber wurde auch spekuliert denn es
passierte unglaublich plötzlich und
hatte heute hier noch eine enorm
wichtige parlamentsdebatte und da
mitreden es geht um viel geld gegen die
energiekosten krise 150 milliarden pfund
ist dass der neue premierminister ist
das prestige-projekt um sich hier
überhaupt erst mal zu präsentieren und
plötzlich kommen zettel die
oppositionsführer die premierministerin
wird etwas erklärt und in diesem moment
unheimlich viel unruhe und diese debatte
ja bericht damit quasi ab und ich glaube
in diesem moment war dann schon klar
worauf das hinausläuft und dann hat man
eben die familienmitglieder die ängste
neben mit prinz charles hendry adword
und prinzessinnen die kinder der queen
zusammengerufen und daneben auch die
enkel prinz william prinz harry und
ja und dann haben die sich wohl von ihr
verabschieden können und dann kam eben
ja vor gut einer halben dreiviertel
stunde dass die offizielle ankündigung
oder die offizielle verkündung dass
queen elizabeth die zweite nicht mehr
ist ganz großbritannien deswegen in
trauer und auch die welt trauert mit
bundespräsident steinmeier hat sich
geäußert er hat gesagt elisabeth die
zweite hat ein jahrhundert geprägt und
er zeigte sich zitat zutiefst traurig
nach dem tod von der queen
und natürlich hat auch die aktuelle
britische premierministerin des trusts
sich geäußert
das erste statement von der aktuellen
britischen premierministerin des tras
zum tod von queen elizabeth 2 andreas
was bedeutet dieser tod für das gesamte
vereinigten königreiches trust hat es
schon angesprochen die queen 70 jahre
auf diesem thron und die mehrheit der
briten kennt ja auch gar kein leben ohne
diese queen
ja ich glaube das ist das ist dass das
absolut entscheidende dass diese queen
ist die absolute konstante über sieben
jahrzehnte in denen sich ja
unglaublichen wandel durchlebt hat
dieses land von von von fast einem
empire noch dass sich am auflösen begann
zu einer neuerfindung rein in die
europäische union raus der brh exit und
so viele dinge die die passiert sind und
die konstante war immer die queen und
das ist wie gesagt ich meine glaube für
für 70 80 prozent der briten die haben
nie eine andere königin erlebt und das
ist eine epochale ereignis es ist eben
auch so dass eine bindung besteht man
mag die queen vielleicht nicht mehr mag
das königshaus vielleicht nicht aber
ohne ist großbritannien gar nicht
vorstellen waren selbst die die
republikaner die es hier gibt sage ich
mal die das ablehnen sind natürlich auch
aufgewachsen mit der queen und reden
über die queen also die queen ist so
präsent das königshaus in all seinen
höhen und tiefen und und diese tiefe
verwurzelung spürt man natürlich vor
allem heute und man muss sagen dass nach
vielen schwierigen jahren nach skandalen
vor allen dingen die ihre familie
betreffen ist das drama um diana charles
und so weiter die queen es immer
verstanden hat das königshaus zu
modernisieren ohne so stark zu verändern
dass man es nicht wiedererkannte und
diese leistung glaube ich es so präsent
dass viele viele ja ich glaube nicht
vorstellen können dass sie jetzt nicht
mehr da ist auch wenn man natürlich
gemerkt hat okay hier geht jemand
langsam und ich meine das nicht
vergessen sie war 96 jahre alt ja
absolut dass es gerade angesprochen
trotzdem muss sich jetzt großbritannien
auf diesen neuanfang ohne queen
elizabeth einstellen wie geht es denn da
jetzt weiter gibt es da schon einen plan
in den nächsten tagen und wochen
ja es gibt da ganz klar ausgearbeitete
pläne die sind hunderte seiten lang zum
beispiel spielt es auch eine riesenrolle
wo die queen nun letztendlich gestorben
ist das ist jetzt eben in schottland
ganz im norden des vereinigten
königreichs auf schloss balmoral und das
versetzt dann verschiedene dinge in
bewegung wenn sie von wohin geleitet
wird um dann nach zehn tagen nach ende
der staatstrauer daneben ihre beisetzung
und den großen gedenkgottesdienst in
westminster abbey dann zur beisetzung in
diesen jobs apple in windsor nebst
ehemann philip und natürlich zu dem was
die queen betrifft wird natürlich auch
mit ihrem ende ist der könig charles
sofort sozusagen da aber er wird morgen
er wird zurück reisen nach london und
dort seiner inthronisierung beiwohnen
das ist nicht die kombination die
krönung aber wird sozusagen offiziell
von einem gremium in saint james palast
bestätigt als könig er wird dann im
parlament sein er wird den
premierminister und das kabinett
ministerin und das kabinett treffen und
damit wird das alles formal gemacht er
wird dann auch auf eine runde durch das
vereinigte königreich gehen durch alle
vier landesteile england wales
schottland und nordirland um dort
sozusagen sich vorzustellen quasi als
neuer könig also da gibt es ganz klar
ausgearbeitete pläne und das wird hier
die nächsten zehn tage in großbritannien
und wahrscheinlich noch weit darüber
hinaus bestimmen was gibt es vielleicht
noch darüber hinaus über über die
thronfolge hinaus ist immer wieder auch
zu lesen dass es pläne gibt dass zum
beispiel die bbc die comedy
ausstrahlungen aussetzt gegebenenfalls
auch pläne an der nationalhymne ist da
schon über darüber schon etwas bekannt
ich glaube jetzt haben wir gerade ein
kurzes ton problem zu unserer leitung 2
andreas stamm nach london ich weiß nicht
andreas und du uns noch hören kannst
gehört ich höre nichts mehr das scheint
nicht so dann gehe ich ganz kurz auf die
natürlich reaktionen auch aus der ganzen
welt ein es kam auch gerade ein
statement von bundeskanzler olaf scholz
bei twitter wir trauern um queen
elizabeth die zweite sie war vorbild
inspiration für millionen auch hier in
deutschland ihr einsatz für die deutsch
britische aussöhnung nach den schrecken
des zweiten weltkriegs bleibt
unvergessen sie wird fehlen ein
trauriger ein schicksalhafter tag für
das vereinigte königreich und diana
zimmermann die ehemalige zdf
studioleiterin in london sie hat viele
jahre das wirken der queen erlebt und
blickt jetzt noch einmal für uns zurück
auf das bewegte leben von ihr
pflichterfüllung das hatte in dieser
wird sich vorgenommen und mit jedem jahr
das sie ihrem motto treu blieb gewann
sie an respekt und anerkennung
eine kerbe ich erkläre vor ihnen allen
dass mein ganzes leben mag es lang oder
kurz seien in ihrem dienst stehen wird
zweiter juni 1953 elizabeth wird zur
königin von großbritannien und
nordirland gekrönt 70 jahre lang hielt
sie dieses amt auf dass ihre eltern sie
vorbereitet hatten sie selbst sagte
immer dass sie ein leben auf dem land
vorgezogen hätte
[Musik]
demonstrativ pflichtbewusst zeigte sie
sich auch im zweiten weltkrieg als kfz
mechanikerin in den mann ihres lebens
prinz verliebt sie sich mit 13 jahren
acht jahre später hochzeit in
westminster abbey
[Musik]
nach dem plötzlichen tod ihres vaters
wird sie über nacht königin muss lernen
pflichten und verantwortung einer
monarchen zu tragen
in ihre tiefste krise gerät die männer
hier als 1997 prinzessin der jänner
stirbt königin elisabeth schweigt über
tage er ist unter dem druck der
öffentlichkeit findet sie worte der
trauer
immer wieder kommt die queen nach
deutschland das letzte mal 2015 ein
besuch zwischen großem jubel und
gedenken an den krieg prinz philip und
sie besuchen das von den briten befreite
lager werken welt
unermüdlich in der wahrnehmung ihrer
pflichten die queen einte die briten
nach den terroranschlägen in london im
juli 2005 ist sie sofort bei den
verletzten
2017 nimmt sie anteil am schicksal der
opfer des brandes im grenzfall hochhaus
ermutigt die nation während der korona
pandemie
selbstdisziplin ruhige gut gelaunte
entschiedenheit und mitgefühl
charakterisieren dieses land nach wie
vor sehr stolz auf das was wir sind
liegt nicht in der vergangenheit in
definiert unsere gegenwart und unsere
zukunft
ihre wohl schwierigste außenpolitische
mission der staatsbesuch in irland 2011
elisabeth kommt und hilft bei der
versöhnung zweier völker mit schwieriger
gemeinsamer geschichte
[Applaus]
weniger erfolgreich ist sie darin zwist
in der eigenen familie zu schlichten die
hoffnung der monarchie durch die heirat
prinz harrys mit der us amerikanischen
schauspielerin megan marke einen
modernen multikulturellen schub zu geben
zerschlägt sich rasch als die beiden
sich von der königlichen familie
lossagen
vereint sieht man die windsors dann erst
wieder zu einem traurigen anlass dem tod
des ehemanns und treuen gefährten der
königin prinz philip
pflichterfüllung mag es dann auch
gewesen sein was er über den schmerz
hinweg half im alter von 96 jahren nahm
sie weiter bis zuletzt öffentliche
termine wahr
mit dieser einzigartigen verlässlichkeit
und jene für die queen so typischen
leichten lächeln das die nation nun
schmerzlich vermissen wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja was bleibt von queen elizabeth der
zweite darüber können wir jetzt sprechen
mit theo koll hier bei uns bei zdf heute
live lange zeit auch korrespondent für
das zdf in london hat auch wie diana
zimmermann mehrere jahre das wirken der
queen erlebt schönen guten tag herr
koller erstmal schön dass sie bei uns
sind gut und hallo herr kohl sie haben
die queen mehrfach treffen können sie
hatten einladungen in den buckingham
palace und jetzt gerade haben wir auch
dieses lächeln für für das sie steht
gesehen aus ihrer sicht was bleibt von
ihr also vielleicht kurz noch zu diesen
begegnungen das war
wirklich eindrucksvoll ich habe ja durch
meine politische journalisten tätigkeit
relativ viele menschen auch in
entsprechende positionen getroffen aber
elisabeth war ja eine ganz kleine person
also wenn man wie ich 190 ist dann ist
das sehr eindrucksvoll klein
aber sie war eine ganz große und sie
hatte eine ganz besondere aura muss ich
sagen wir haben die kollegen haben sich
mal den spaß gemacht bei einem der
ersten treffen der sich bayer hatte dann
wird man jahr vorgestellt dann gibt es
jemanden der dann in dieser langen reihe
der menschen die ihr vorgestellt werden
dann präsentiert und sagt dass es herr
oder frau soundso
und dann begrüßt man sich und wechselt
ein paar worte und
es wird immer ein foto gemacht natürlich
insbesondere für die gäste und bei mir
war es so dass offen sich mehrere fotos
gemacht wurden und die kollegen haben
sich dann alle fotos angeschaut und
haben gesehen dass sich die hacken
zusammen geschlagen habe also es war
wirklich diese aura von ihr war
unvergleichlich und
etwas was auch ausgestrahlt hat also das
waren ich habe einmal einen abend
erlebte in london in einem kleineren
kreis da waren vielleicht vier oder fünf
tische ich war natürlich am
unwichtigsten tisch aber
da war es dann so dass man das essen
wird serviert und natürlich tisch der
königin als erster und meint ich war
immer der letzte und wenn man in england
lebt weiß man dass eigentlich der
nachtisch in der regel das beste ist und
es war aber dann natürlich so dass essen
ist beendet wenn die königin auf steht
und sie wurde als erster bekam natürlich
ernst erst die ehre ihre speisenfolge
und wir bekamen dann irgendwann unseren
pudding auf den tisch gestellt und dann
stand die königin auf und das essen war
beendet also
will nur sagen dass fans
unvergessliche momente auch eines
korrespondenten da seins in london
vielen dank dass sie diese eindrücke
diese anekdoten hier mit uns teilen ich
habe auch immer wieder im blick die
reaktion die aus der ganzen welt
reinkommen der französische präsident
immer manuell mack hat sich auch
geäußert er sagte es sei eine königin
mit herz gewesen er zitierte ihre
majestät königin so dass die zweite
verkörperte über 70 jahre lang die
kontinuität und einheit der britischen
nation sie selber haben auch gerade das
gefühlige beschrieben
dieses königin mit herz teilen sie das
auch ja da muss man natürlich
gewisse abstriche machen weil die
erziehung von jemandem wie elisabeth
zukünftigen königin die hat natürlich
bestimmte bedingungen mit sich gebracht
und natürlich gab es gibt es lange
geschichten darüber dass sie als junge
mutter charles auch lange alleine
gelassen hat dass es da eine
zurückhaltung gibt auch eine bestimmte
sagen kälte zwischen zwischen mutter und
charles aber das sind einfach
bedingungen in einer in einer monarchie
in einer
ja in einer familie die gleichzeitig
eine staats familie ist und wo natürlich
formen
oftmals stärker zum tragen kommen als
normales menschliches verhalten also ich
erinnere sehr ein bild das die königin
war lange auf reisen im commonwealth
über monate und charles war in england
geblieben und als sie dann ankam am
bahnhof hat sie erst mal alle
würdenträger begrüßt und irgendwann dann
ihren sohn das sind dann bedingungen die
gehören im grunde zum beruf in
anführungsstrichen der königin die aber
natürlich für für andere menschen sehr
befremdlich sind also insofern würde ich
da bei diesem herz von außen betrachtet
kleine abstriche machen aber sie war
jemand der in dieser in dieser aura die
sie hat ein land repräsentiert hat wir
haben ja in großbritannien ein anderes
politisches system als in deutschland
bei uns sitzt das parlament in einem
halbrund das heißt wir haben eigentlich
ein eher konsensual es politisches
system in england sitzen sich die beiden
großen parteien gegenüber das heißt da
ist ein sehr viel
antagonistische responses verhältnis was
ja auch immer wieder dazu geführt hat
dass die politischen verhältnisse sich
radikal geändert haben dann gab es eine
labour regierung die hat firmen konzerne
verstaatlicht dann kam maggie thatcher
die hat die
gewerkschaften fast abgeschafft also da
gab es große brüche und die gibt es
immer wieder in diesem land und insofern
ist eine monarchie und eine frau wie
königin elizabeth ii zweite es war noch
bedeutender weil sie das land wie eine
klammer auch politisch zusammenhält
emotional zusammenhält und das hat sie
auf eine weise verstanden sehr
zurückhaltend wenig profil zeigen das
war auch eine qualität dass man wirklich
auch ganz schwer nur
lesen konnte gelegentlich an symbolen
was sie politisch denkt wo sie
vielleicht eine leichte präferenz hat
aber damit hat sie geschafft das ganze
land zu repräsentieren und zu zu einen
und darzustellen und wenn man natürlich
eine situation hat wo die königin der
staatsoberhaupt auf jeder münze ist
vielen geldschein denn alles mögliche
nach der monarchie benannt ist dann ist
es eine klammer die sehr indirekt wirkt
was natürlich im negativen sinne auch
zur die klassengesellschaft
verlängert und und viele negative folgen
natürlich auch hat
herzlichen dank für die einschätzung was
mich vielleicht abschließend noch
interessieren würde sie beschreiben
gerade diese klammer der der queen auf
großbritannien befürchten sie dass wenn
diese klammer jetzt wegbricht dass sich
das auch negativ auf großbritannien
auswirken wird auch das gefühl der leute
oder glauben sie dass in diesem moment
auch eben die einigkeit auch weiter
entstehen könnte
also ich befürchte dass die klammer sich
abschwächt die
die jetzige die jetzige konstellation
prinz charles ist jemand der sehr an
statur gewonnen hat aber der natürlich
nicht diese welle der sympathie
auslöst wie seine mutter und er war
jemand der sehr viel stärker sich bemüht
fühlte meinungen zu äußern positionen
einzubringen in die debatte da ging es
um architektur mitunter auch politische
äußerungen und das hat immer den
nachteil dass man ein teil der
bevölkerung damit gegen sich aufbringt
weil sie anderer meinung sind das hat
die königin immer vermieden und insofern
ist glaube ich die bindekraft die
prinzen prinz charles und jetzt könig
wir wissen ja noch nicht genau wie er
heißt ob er wirklich könig charles
heißen wird das muss gar nicht der fall
sein
also dass der neue könig eine geringere
bindekraft hat und das in einer
situation wo großbritannien wirklich vor
großen problemen steht
wir haben in europa überall nach den
angriffskrieg der russen auf die ukraine
natürlich massive wirtschaftliche
probleme die sind den großbritannien
möglicherweise noch größer als bei uns
aber das land ist natürlich auch
gebeutelt vom brh exit ist zerrissen
weil viele junge leute dann auch gesagt
haben was haben wir da gemacht wir haben
gar nicht mit abgestimmt und jetzt sind
wir nicht mehr teil der europäischen
union dann haben sie die entwicklungen
in den einzelnen landesteilen wir haben
ja eine sonate d vision in england das
heißt oder in großbritannien muss man
sagen tony blair hat damals weil es
starke bestrebungen in schottland gab
für unabhängigkeit und hat er gesagt wir
schaffen im grunde eine unausgewogene
art von föderalismus das heißt die
schotten haben besonders viele
sonderrechte bekommen haben ein eigenes
parlament haben eine eigene regierung
die walliser die nicht so autonom sein
wollten haben etwas weniger bekommen die
engländer haben im grunde gar nichts
eigenes bekommen sondern sind in
gewisser weise weil london zu england
gehört dann noch der dominierende teil
aber da ist große sprengkraft drin dass
das land auseinander strebt und da war
königin elisabeth immer eine wichtige
klammer auch emotional und wenn das sich
abschwächt könnte es sein dass
beispielsweise die tendenz bei den
schotten sich verstärken wird sich
abzusetzen von london wir haben ja bei
liszts der neuen premier ministerin
jetzt erlebt dass sie im grunde die
schotten schon vor den kopf gestoßen hat
und gesagt hat man müsse auf die
schottische premier ministerin überhaupt
nicht hören also da ist glaube ich eine
gewisse sprengkraft in der in der
zukunft herzlichen dank theo koll für
diese analyse auch noch mal zum schluss
und auch für die einblicke in die
begegnung und mit queen elizabeth der
zweite theo koll lange zeit auch in
london für das zdf unterwegs schönen
dank für diese einordnung gerne
und das war's theo koll hat auch
angesprochen hat wie genau die
nachfolgeregelung vonstatten geht da
gibt es auch gerade die frische
information dass es offiziell bestätigt
ist dass charles künftig könig charles
der dritte heißt ich habe immer wieder
auch für euch gemeinsam mit dem team die
meldungen von anderen
spitzenpolitikerinnen und politikern aus
der ganzen welt im blick und auch da ist
natürlich die anteilnahme sehr groß
kommission eu kommissionspräsidenten von
der leyen schreibt zb erlauben sie mir
ihrer majestät der königlichen familie
und dem britischen volk mein
aufrichtiges beileid im namen der
europäischen union auszudrücken eine
weitere beileidsbekundung die haben wir
auch vorliegen in einem statement von
justin
world
resort
also ein sichtlich mitgenommen hat das
dehnt rudow am tränen sehen wir da bei
ihm kann er da ja wichtig auch für das
kann man wolf wir können jetzt sprechen
mit einer weiteren experten und zwar
ist das
da muss ich mal ganz kurz noch mal auf
meinem zettel schauen julia melcher ist
das zdf adelsexpertin hat für uns auch
immer wieder das britische königshaus im
blick schönen guten abend von welcher
entschuldigen sie erst mal dass ich dann
noch mal nachschauen musste wir haben
gerade herren trio gehört tränen in den
augen ganz viel anteilnahme vielleicht
auch noch mal aus ihrer expertise wie
ist diese persönlichkeit queen elizabeth
zu beschreiben als ein jahrhundert
königin es gibt keine person
ihresgleichen die halt so viele zeiten
durchgemacht hat sie hat alle ups and
downs überwunden und sie ist ein solches
als inbegriff von
kontinuität oder auch über alle
generationen hinweg sind die menschen
fasziniert von ihrer königin gewesen in
großbritannien aber auch in der ganzen
welt also sie ist etwas einzigartiges
und ich glaube auch dass wir jetzt halt
in den nächsten tagen feierlichkeiten
erleben werden von historischer
dimension die es noch nie gegeben hat
ein start
ergebnis der ganz einzigartigen art und
das wird halt einfach dieser dieser
großen königin tribut zollen
sie haben gerade schon die ersten
charakteristika angesprochen womit
würden sie vielleicht auch am ehesten
beschreiben
mit disziplin und haltung denn sie ist
natürlich in diese königliche familie
hineingeboren worden
aber es waren doch eigentlich sehr viele
zufälle in der geschichte dass sie
überhaupt königin geworden ist einmal
weil damals edward der achte ihr onkel
unverhofft abgedankt hat so kam
überhaupt ihr vater auf den thron und
sie hatte keinen bruder so kam sie zu
dem recht königin zu werden eigentlich
galt damals noch an der britischen
thronfolge männer bevorzugt aber es war
also ein großer glücksfall in der
geschichte für das britische königreich
das elisabeth die zweite
70 jahre lang königin dieses königreich
sein könnte und dass wir haben wir ja
auch noch mal gesehen diesen diesen
einen moment den die königin hatte jetzt
bei den feierlichkeiten zu ihrem 70
thronjubiläum ja absolut die bilder die
sind und ich glaube ich alle noch sehr
präsent
tolle bilder ein tolles event ganz
großbritannien außer sich und nun eben
aber die der schock und die trauer
natürlich auch sehr groß wir haben es
gerade gehört in sachen
nachfolgeregelung frau melchior ist die
offizielle bestätigung bekommen es heißt
künftig könig charles der dritte wie
sehen weitere nachfolgeregelung im
britischen königshaus was wissen sie
darüber
neue thronfolger dass es prinz william
er wird auch bald prinz steht neben der
neue prinz of wales sein das ist der
titel der traditionell dem thronfolger
gebührt insofern rutschen jetzt in der
thronfolge folge alle einen schritt
weiter nach oben aber es wird natürlich
auch jetzt irgendwie sie haben
vielleicht auch in der ersten rede von
prinz charles wenn er sich an die nation
wenden wird
heraushören morgen wird prinz charles
zum könig charles
proklamiert er ist schon königs mit
sofortiger wirkung ist er könig geworden
aber morgen findet die proklamation
stadt das ist eigentlich der erste große
feierliche akt in den in dem abschieds
feierlichkeiten in dem großem
zeremoniell dass wir in den nächsten
zehn tagen erwarten werden und prinz
charles könig starb der dritte daran
müssen wir uns jetzt alle gewöhnen was
ja auch sehr schwierig ist nach
70 jahren wir können uns ja alle nicht
an eine zeit erinnern ohne die queen
also könig charles der dritte wird
morgen danach aufbrechen und die
einzelnen nationen bereisen also er wird
nach wales fahren er wird nach
schottland fahren und nach nordirland
wird sich überall zeigen und der sarg
der königin wird aufgebaut jetzt erst
einmal in schottland wo sie gestorben
ist und er wird dann überführt in den
nächsten tagen nach london und dann in
etwa fünf tagen werden wir den ersten
großen feierlichen akt erwarten wenn der
sagt dann mit einer sehr prunkvollen
militär parade vom buckingham palast in
die houses of parliament überführt wird
wo die bevölkerung dann abschied nehmen
kann bevor dann am letzten tag der
großen staatstrauer die königin in einer
großen trauerfeier mit staatsgästen
verabschiedet wird und am selben tag
dann der beigesetzt wird bei ihrem prinz
philip vor dem von dem wir uns vor
anderthalb jahren verabschiedet haben
julia melchior ist königshaus expertin
für das zdf und von melchior wir können
jetzt auch gerade bilder sehen
buckingham palace die liegen uns vor da
können wir hinschauen pilgern ganz ganz
viele menschen hin hören wir und müssen
wir jetzt auch glaube ich in den
nächsten augenblicken sehen können wir
vielleicht zusammen drauf schauen
ich warte da noch ein bisschen
ansonsten falls die bilder uns nicht
vorliegen frau manager frage ich sie
trotzdem natürlich auch noch mal da sind
sie da haben wir sie bilder vor dem
buckingham palace also ganz ganz viele
menschen versammelt andreas stamm hat
das vorhin auch ein beginn des streams
gesagt dass er weg musste weil so viele
hingekommen sind lichter sehen wir da
eine sehr ruhige der stille atmosphäre
so scheint es auf den ersten blick frau
welcher was sagen diese bilder diese
anteilnahme auch aus
das erstaunliche ist es ja wir mussten
ja alle schon seit vielen jahren
eigentlich auch damit rechnen dass die
queen stirbt weil sie einfach sehr alt
war und gerade also auch in den letzten
anderthalb jahren seit dem tod von ihrem
mann doch auch sehr abgebaut hat aber in
dem moment in dem die nachricht dann um
die welt ging man dann doch relativ
fassungslos dass es also dieses
historische ereignis jetzt auch
eingetreten ist weil man sich einfach
einen einen eine britische monarchie
eigentlich gar nicht richtig ohne die
queen vorstellen kann ja absolut das
haben wir aufgearbeitet auch bisher in
diesem stream die queen einfach als
instanz als als lichtgestalt das kommt
auch von euch liebe userinnen und user
immer wieder hier im chat sie war so
eine großartige frau obwohl eine königin
und eine königin und auch einfach ein
vorbild als mensch in vielerlei hinsicht
das schreibt veronika frau jackie cola
schreibt bei youtube mein größtes
beileid an weil die briten haben jetzt
eben auch ihre besondere identität
verloren und frau merkel sie haben das
gerade angesprochen wir wir haben die
bilder gesehen vor dem buckingham palace
vielleicht können wir die auch ganz kurz
noch einmal
zeigen es gab viele probleme in der
vergangenheit viele diskussionen auch
innerhalb der briten rund um diese
monarchie und jetzt eben doch diese
anteilnahme was bedeutet dass vielleicht
auch für die zukunft der monarchie sehen
sie da eine chance oder der einigkeit
auch in der bevölkerung diesbezüglich ja
das erstaunliche ist ja dass dieses
königshaus ja auch oft in der kritik
steht oder dass es auch viele briten
gibt die gar nicht hinter dieser
staatsform monarchie stehen aber auch
gerade die jungen leute die irgendwie
gar kein verständnis dafür haben warum
ein
per geburt jemand ein recht dazu hat das
staatsoberhaupt zu sein aber trotzdem
waren sich eigentlich alle darüber einig
dass die queen ihr
einzigartiges staatsoberhaupt war
insofern wird es für das königshaus
sicherlich jetzt auch in zukunft größere
herausforderungen geben wobei aber könig
charles der dritte der auch in den
letzten jahren durchaus an zuspruch
gewonnen hat auch bei den jungen leuten
und was eine große rolle spielt es dann
doch auch schon die nächste generation
es ist ja sehr schwierig mit teils ist
jemand jetzt in den topjob vorgerückt er
hat jetzt quasi den sprung in den auf
der karriereleiter gemacht in einem
alter wo andere menschen schon ihren
wohlverdienten ruhestand genießen und es
ist ja auch nicht so dass er in den
letzten jahren völlig untätig war ganz
im gegenteil er hat unheimlich viel
bewegt im hintergrund aber jetzt dann
doch in einem alter wo ich würde mal
sagen wo man jetzt nicht so auf dem
höhepunkt der vitalität ist kommt er
also jetzt auf einen job der auch viel
von ihm verlangt von der queen wussten
wir dass sie 363 tage im jahr also an
allen tagen außer ostersonntag und an
weihnachten hat sie die staatspapiere
studiert und sich eingelesen also sie
war immer erreichbar sie war immer
informiert über das politische
tagesgeschehen und
jetzt trifft dieses dieses amt halt
könig charles mit anfang 70 an seiner
seite camilla und es ist sehr sehr
wichtig jetzt auch dass sie die junge
generation auch schon einbinden das tun
sie auch also sein sohn prinz william
der nächste prince of wales an seiner
seite herzogin kate sind eine wichtige
entlastung und die beiden finden halt
auch eine große zustimmung in der
bevölkerung
was dieser familie aber sicherlich auch
fehler jetzt sind figuren wie harry und
megan die halt auch sehr viele kreise in
der bevölkerung angesprochen haben die
sich eigentlich nicht für die monarchie
begeistern können und man kann nur
hoffen dass ich jetzt über den tod der
queen
diese familie auch ein stückweit
versöhnt denn es ist doch ein sehr
großes zerwürfnis leider zwischen harry
und dem rest der familie
vielen dank für ihre einschätzungen wir
schauen jetzt noch mal gemeinsam auch
auf die live bilder vor dem buckingham
palace die haben wir gerade gesehen sehr
sehr viele menschen die in strömen die
ihre anteilnahme zeigen wollen das wird
sich wahrscheinlich auch bis tief in die
nacht weiter ziehen auch in den nächsten
tagen natürlich frau melcher da haben
wir die bilder nochmal eine riesige
menschenmenge sie haben auch gerade
schon angesprochen
das erbe der queen elizabeth ii zweite
70 jahre auf dem thron insgesamt 25
1753 tage hat sie dort verbracht und
jetzt eben prinz charles könig der
dritte sie haben gerade schon
thematisiert aus ihrer sicht wie wird er
dieses erbe denn antreten
und vielleicht dann auch weiterführen
also es kommt ja jetzt für charles nicht
plötzlich dieser wechsel ist
schon seit vielen jahren spielt er
hinter den kulissen eine sehr
entscheidende rolle er wird sicherlich
an der einheit natürlich der nation auch
versuchen festzuhalten er wird auch
versuchen auch die jungen menschen
anzusprechen er steht für themen wie
nachhaltigkeit und ökologische
landwirtschaft und so was was sie alles
auch sehr sehr gut bei den jungen leuten
ankommt ich glaube dass wir sicherlich
weniger zeremoniell erleben werden das
ist ja doch etwas was wir an königin
elizabeth das eigentlich was einzigartig
war an der pram britischen königshaus
auch in allen anderen königshäusern in
europa oder auf der welt haben dass so
was nicht mehr gesehen dieses
zeremoniell
das halt immer noch so hoch gehalten
worden ist wenn sie in der goldenen
kutsche zur parlamentseröffnung gefahren
ist und im vollen ornat mit dem herren
inthronisiert worden ist also insofern
ist auch zu erwarten dass diese diese
der die der die trauerfeier und die
beisetzung der queen also ein
zeremonieller höhepunkt werden ein
historisches ereignis wie wir sicherlich
danach nie wieder erleben werden sagt
julia melchior königshaus experten für
das zdf jetzt stimmt auch der name
herzlichen dank für ihre zeit hier heute
abend bei zdf heute live und dass sie
mit uns teilgenommen haben und erklärt
haben was für eine bedeutung der tod von
queen elizabeth der zweiten für ganz
großbritannien und die monarchie in
zukunft haben wird
queen elizabeth die zweite ist im alter
von 96 jahren gestorben
70 jahre lang auf dem thron und gerade
schon auch haben wir es gesagt insgesamt
1753 tage doch wir haben das auch gehört
sie war nicht nur königin ihr habt das
auch im chat geschrieben sie war
aushängeschild sie war die lichtgestalt
einfach eine instanz für die gesamte
bevölkerung jetzt ist die queen
gestorben und ganz großbritannien steht
vor der frage wie geht es weiter erste
informationen erste einschätzungen
eindrücke bilder wie habt ihr heute
bekommen hier bei uns von zdf heute live
weitere infos und natürlich auch noch
weitere eindrücke von vor ort die geht
es heute ab 21 uhr 45 natürlich auch im
heute journal vielen dank für eure
anteilnahme vielen dank dass ihr teil in
unserer sendung gewesen seid bis zum
nächsten mal danke und tschüss